um you lied to me the other night what
do you mean oh what did I lie to you
about
well the other night we're at the Improv
you say you have to go
so you want to perform me and just hear
me out okay right you want before me I
have to go I have to go say that it's so
dramatically I know but you did did you
not say that did I snap you didn't do
this okay that's what your um podcast
partner does probably played this
Michael yeah yeah yeah but you okay
Michael right you're a good kid but so
you go I want to go before you and I
have to go because I have to go so I go
oh he has to go so you went up killed it
you killed it right thanks man and I go
up right and
I'm so Furious during my whole show I
know why because in my periphery I could
see you standing was that a full word
peripheral there it is
you know you're being rude right now I'm
sorry you're very rude right now I'm
trying to get this out yeah and then we
can move on with that right so am I
peripheral
right I see you against the wall with
your arm truck I was watching were you
not watching I was watching I watched
your whole set right but why did you lie
say they have to go
I did I hate what cops do that I hate
what Comics do that I didn't know
because we were on the schedule at like
you were already booked after me
I was yeah it was me then you I did the
first show so usually you know I'm not
going to tell you how Comedy Works what
is your writing process but but I was on
the seven o'clock so there was like I
was just there for three hours I'm
eating spinach dip by myself it's lonely
it's weird yeah yeah there's a lot of
people smoking weed up there I'm getting
uncomfortable yeah what is that up with
that too I don't know people
it's a little green room there's no
they're not none of them are on the show
none of them were Comics right and
they're just but there's something about
that green room where you're like I need
to do drugs yeah Hollywood who's up
there just like people friends and I
don't want and and don't cancel me don't
cancel me and I'm just telling truth
keep the camera on Bobby
just Bobby just Bobby I'm saying
truthism's all right okay this is not
you know I mean a slam to any race
ethnicity or background
all right what happened after all right
so
people really respect the green rooms at
comedy clubs nowadays you every once in
a while I see a guy just sniffing a
Miata key
for the most part at the store at The
Improv you don't really see people just
are just sitting there they're on their
phone there's nothing wild it's always
the people who are outside of it that
are doing the most you know that's
interesting that you say that and I
agree with you Trev yeah of course all
right but like people will look at me
and they'll be like like a friend of a
friend will be like thanks for asking
for that was very nice but can I do
drugs in here I'm like I don't know I
don't know what do you mean try let me
try they will like well like a friend of
everyone was like literally doing
cocaine and I was like I don't want to
be the why am I the gatekeeper here
because if you're on the lineup in the
green room right and they're not it's
your green room that is true okay so you
can do whatever you want care for your
comfort right yeah but I gotta doing
coke in the corners and a lot of comfort
you know what I'm saying like he should
not be there
wait I don't want to tell a coked out
guy no you know because find meth don't
yeah if it's mad
they'll pull your baby they'll pull my
baby no they boil babies oh boy oh boy
yeah yeah yeah that's a long time in
Riverside a lot of things happen a
couple a boiler baby yeah Riverside is
um
why is the IE just out here like that
great shows so much fun that's every
time he has a show in the IE he almost
I love it there it's great they have
great math that's where it comes from
right I believe so it's always inland
right right because in San Diego Vista
you know back in the day was placed and
that was come more inland
oh that's right you guys what about the
desert
that's what is that this is lack of
water so they just gets steamy and hot
in the area and you're like I just need
to do drugs no there's just not a lot of
things around so